bonjour et bienvenue dans le studio
diagonale tv rondo 8 du championnat
français 2015 50 en 2015 avec sophie
millet bonjour sophy super championnat
avec donc puisque quatre titres au
compteur
oui ça fait pas mal c'est bien mais ça
fait longtemps que j'ai pas dis donc tu
rêve d'en ajouter un cinquième
j'aimerais bien vous empêche pas très
bien parti
ça va être difficile cette année mais
voilà donc je fais d'assez bonne partie
donc je suis assez satisfaite mais ça
reste encore possible parce que
aujourd'hui tu as réussi une belle
partie
tu as marqué un point les deux leaders
jouer ensemble donc y en aura plus
qu'une ou deux vantaux assis à nine qui
gagnes et tu risques jouer face à la
demi-heure en fait tu vas jouer face à
le migrant notamment dernière ronde avec
les blancs voir quand même gagner les
deux prochaines parties joueurs et puis
après ils vont quand même ira donc
encore lui mais c'est encore possible
c'était toujours en course était
derrière et tu t'attends moment quoi
donc à il ya un an difficile dans ce
championnat c'est ta partie face à
membres n'en sais rien a monté ce n'est
pas très chanceux je n'ai pas été très
inspiré au niveau de l'ouverture
j'ai répété une ligne que je pensais
qu'il était bonne pour les noirs
et en fait ça s'est très mal passé voilà
jouer tout très vite ils étaient bien
préparés nous manger cuisine perdu sans
jouer et c'est vrai que le plus râlant
c'était que le lendemain elle mirage ou
contre elle avec les blancs et joue une
ouverture que j'avais prévu de jouer n'a
voté ce coup ci j'avais les blancs et à
leganes dans l'ouverture donc à te dire
ça use ou l'inversé
balin c'était un point de différence
donc c'est quasiment puisque vous moi
c'était vraiment tout de suite dans la
préparation c'était fini donc bon c'est
vrai que c'était un petit peu voilà
c'était pas très chanceux l'on va dire
t'as vu tomber de haut quand tu as vu
que cette préparation qui va c'était un
peu dur à se concentrer cette partie
d'ailleurs quand je voyais j'avais
l'écran juste en face de moi et je
voyais tous les cons que que je
connaissais voilà ça se fait partie des
aléas alors en attendant ronde 8 ça
quand même juste un point de retard
était troisième en fait tu donc tu suis
quand même les premières avec un corps
croire on a joué donc tout est encore
possible d'autant que tu dois jouer la
dernière ronde face à venir avec les
blancs on enregistre on n'a pas encore
le résultat de la partie entre almira et
nino donc tout ce qui est sûr c'est que
eh bien il y en a une d2 que tu va
rattraper où tu vas être plus qu'à une
demi point des deux donc tout était
encore possible s'est ouvert et
aujourd'hui d'être parti ça c'est
intéressant
c'est assez tendue à un moment donné
peut-être j'ai un peu laissé échapper
c'est parce que c'est devenu compliqué
alors que je pense que j'avais une bonne
maîtrise de la partie
et puis bon finalement finalement j'ai
bien transposé en finale je pense que la
finale était gagnante mais bon ça s'est
pas joué à grand chose c'était assez
tendu
on va voir ça dans ta partie donc face à
mademoiselle soubie rohff ou alors c'est
parti
la hourquette 4006 je suis donc
française des quêtes des cinq qui va
laisser trois toiles et c'est ray kelly
m 6,4 y y et si ce n'est pas la variante
forcément toujours aussi souffre ou de
casser les deux grandes variantes l
avant a joué plutôt fou beckham dont moi
j'ai vu qu'elle avait fait gagner six
mois j'ai un peu regardé les 2e 5e ça y
est aussi jouer face à un grand coup et
fuji 5
donc tu as joué que 5 kg f17 f4f 4 en
lui dédiant ce tour à tour c'est de
jouer ces cinq de jouer contre ce tout
petit chêne de pions oui il est blanc
essayer de garder un bon contrôle du
centre ces cinq qu'elle élève 3 c'est
simple attaque ici on développe pour
protéger aussi aux quatre en rajoute et
c6 fouet trois pression au centre les
morsures protéger la classe des 4 l à
fait à 6 à 6 voilà on veut prendre de
l'espace avel dame d'accord on donne des
deux tu attendait jusqu'ici fouet pour
l'instant c'est connu d'accord b5 et bon
c'est vrai que c'est dingue je n'avais
pas trop révisé donc je vous dis que
j'ai un petit peu hésité parce que ici à
pas mal de coups possibles
3 joue à trois mois j'ai fait plus en
france et 5 ici paraît bon voilà et en
fait ici elle a réfléchi ce qui m'a
étonné parce que j'ai joué c'est fini il
ya quelques mois aux championnats du
monde contraire une accroche oui premier
tour c'est ça c'est ça et
voilà donc je sais pas peut-être qu'elle
avait oublié c'est vrai que je joue
aussi d'autres choses peut-être qu'elle
avait révisé plusieurs choses
différentes
donc moi même à jouer coup normal vous
prince et 5
à noter sur ce championnat du monde tu
as joué donc l'américaine y accroche au
premier trail tu as perdu ce match mais
on a suivi
on ad on a fait des émissions spéciales
à championnat du monde et on a suivi ce
match rien on ne rien faire et que tu
fasses un ou deux tours de plus voire
plus
c'est vrai que j'ai eu du mal un peu
contre les monstres sc c'est la première
fois que j'étais qualifié et c'était
ouais j'ai pas réussi à gérer
l'événement c'est dommage parce que j'ai
eu ma chance dans les deux parties voilà
pour la prochaine fois j'espère c'est
l'américaine ouais c'était un bon match
à tous alors dans le brownie bas donc à
la fessée s'il prend d'accord et la food
& 3 tranquille qui est un peu le nouveau
coup en fait je ne blâme à la mode
alors oui en fait depuis sept ans à des
quatre c'est chaud parce que on
s'appelle une pièce c'est un peu
compliqué on leur bateau des 4 way
caillé prendre des quêtes comprend voilà
mon impression c'est par une pièce de
scud a attaqué deux fois mais défendu
deux fois donc il ya double prise la
cavale et prend kelly prend et la cie le
fou prend je reprends du fou oui
cavaliers prend 4 et j'attaque la tour
et gagner donc je vais récupérer avec au
final et la dame en récupère le cavalier
avec une bonne position
d'accord la tourette attaque et ça c'est
la couette mais on peut prendre du
cavalier c'est un peu différent peut
prendre les cavaliers et il ya ça marche
pas parce que si je regarde un peu parce
que s'il faut prendre ou prend quand on
fait fut le cas il ya foule prend ces
trois là il a damé floue et donc non de
la meilleure course et ses cavaliers 4
allez on fait parfois le cas tout de
suite 4 ça marche un peu moins bien
d'accord ça marche un peu moins que les
quatre attaques le fou voilà et je me
menace en fait je me laisse ses trois
tumeurs
ces trois ans simplement une et puis le
police en bas et à la fin cavalier est
fou attaque le fou c5 et tu as tu un peu
foutu menace aussi cavale et prof ou non
à la cie jeunesse qui avait les fronts
fouquet cavaliers qu'elle les prend pour
être un des cats et là ça doit me
prendre des quêtes il n'écoule il faut
le voir ça ils menacent aussi car elle
prend effectivement cavale et prend on
prend ici et si la dame prend il ya fou
ici qui sort en b5 et chez coran prend
le feu et l'a jamais perdu
il nous fait là je vais récupérer même
pièce de manière forcée
la troupe est donc si c'est la variante
à fait hélas 2006 s'en va par exemple
s'il vient en ciel vient en suit pas
cette poule b 6 allez on a sept
qu'est-ce qui se passe
le passager des cavaliers des six
qu'elle ait des six échecs foe quatre
échecs au rwanda est toujours là et
sourd et et oui la tour est attaqué et
c'est on récupère la pièce bon faut
connaître un sérieux parce que sinon oui
c'est pas facile à trouver sur
l'échiquier donc
c'est ici ouais et donc la laf et l'a
fait le principal qui était menée 6 est
donc ici la menace éventuellement des
quatre voies la menace le fou nous aussi
donc faut s 2 est en fait bon l'idée
vides et des blancs en gros c'est voilà
d'essayer de rentrer dans une finale en
échangeant le phocéen contre le fond est
boueux en échangeant les dames et après
profité du fait que le cavalier à la
casse des cats et que le fou ces mythes
va être assez faible parce que voilà ce
qui est blanche derrière un pare feu
s'est vite faible plus une belle case
pour tasser à noter que le deuxième
cavalier peut aussi sauter souvent ça
jusque avaient lieu deux qu'il ya une
arrivée 4 et positionnement ça que c'est
très bien c'est un petit avantage là la
fesfut bessette vous laisse est d'accord
pour éventuellement grand roque et moi
j'ai fait à 3 à 3 ans si oui parce que
bon parfois je peux avoir des idées
peut-être de jouer b4 pour forcer
justement les changes
et oui la proue d'un pas de case et s'il
sent by à la dame donc effectivement
voilà en même temps moi j'évite tout et
quatre aux qualités qu être qu'il va
venir nous donner nous qui courent on va
dire mais elle a fait tour ses huit dont
celui en fait son idée je pense qu'ils
reportent donc et rauque pas en fait je
pense que son idée c'était sûr bekkat
elle a peut-être cavaliers prend b4 est
là depuis on prend v4 souffrent des
quatre caves ambeis il lui faut trois
ans et trois mois me alain fouquet
attaque la dame
ah oui j'avais d'accord à et fou prend
dames et mais simplement prend le
cavalier la dame et cloud donc on
récupère le matos non mesdames france 3
va nous mettre une pièce moi oui
le français 3e pas dire que ça marche
pas ça fonctionne pas on pouvait quand
même faire b4 alors d'apprendre en f2
avec le christ et 3 est en l'air ces
bécanes prend expliqué wayne on va
regarder ça il faut être sûr si vite
c'est ça à chaque le cavaly oui dimpre
en droit prend maintenant le cavalier
est quasiment en prison il suffit de
faire son travail et prendre cinq
épreuves et kate doivent aller prendre
b4 et le cavaly c3 haute marche pas donc
wait en see
céline sas à contrecarrer la poussée b4
donc là j'ai juste rockets tranquille
oui ouf
et là je pense qu'elle a fait une faute
a fait que ya cinq ans un petit peu trop
ambitieux ma vie alors est têtu je sais
pas peut-être faire
six courts pour contrôler l'idée en fait
j'ai fait après ou alors je sais alors
essayé de rentrer quand même dans la
finale parce que pourrait peut-être que
peut faire caler bsca et c4 et avoir un
peu de jeu d'accord parce que là elle a
fait cavalier à 5 mais maintenant j'ai
f5 kalia 5
hélas les blancs f5 classe et voilà et
là c'est vrai que d'un coup la dame
arrivant j'ai cinq est aussi menacée sur
le sur leur base même si le roi rock
c'est très dangereux
la cil au maroc il y aura sera sûrement
aussi saoulé 6 casse le rock la dame qui
derrière vienne en justice pour faire
l'essai s'il perd dangereux il ya des
fous proche 7 est possible aussi
vraiment ça fait mal je pense que ça
gagne tout de suite fait dangereux donc
du coup le roi est au centre
mais ça c'est une mauvaise nouvelle
voilà donc
elle a fait qu'elle et ses 4 quand même
alors ça attaque la dame et là j'ai fait
d'amener 5
normal c'est finalement la sous-estimer
la à l'arrivée de la dame ici pasqua
calé un peu raté stylet équipe 5 2005
ouais
la febo g6 ça m'apparaît du mercou parce
que s'il est cependant g7 et touquet va
s'effondrer je pense alors j'ai six mais
le problème c'est qu'on voit tout les
classements à 6 ans vont affaiblir dit
sur soumah c'est le rôle problème et
willow récente enquête froid 6 7 3 6 6
prises donc déjà les pions sont éclatés
et la colonne f est ouverte alors à la
une petite pression quand même ici un
fait ouais mais bon c'est vrai qu'en
fait à chaque fois ci la coin b2 je peux
juste laisser faire revenir avec
qu'avait lieu de est juste ça perd du
temps en fait tout simplement
ouais pas le problème c'est qu'il ya des
menaces directes sur moi donc c'est
difficile c'est dur là j'ai fait damage
si j'ai un peu hésité damage 4 en fait
avec la même aidé toujours de faire
[ __ ] angers 6,5 damage cap par rapport
à la haye la partie c'est un grand péché
roi des 8
oui on peut pas venir en début dit sa
hâte à créhen mais là en fait je me suis
dit qu'elle pouvait prendre ma relève de
fr pirac prise compétir avec d'une
foudre a troqué ses je peux pas et en
fait je peux pas faire cavalier g5 parce
que ben f2 les choses tout oui ça marche
pas la même
et oui surtout obliger scène comme la
tour est en fuite
c'est plus attention je valais alors que
bon ben là je veux ma télé c'est la capa
poids et ça marche ça marche c'est pas
trés un don qu'il fallait empêcher le
rock
j'ai fait de mal si ce mec a l'air très
bons donc ici tu empêches l'europe qui
menace déjà tout de suite vos proches et
6 échecs ce qu'on peut pas reprendre
voire même des dames g7
on sait jamais il faut calculer mais on
serait rangé 6 c'est la grosse
maintenant la grosse menace on a tout à
fait donc là les parties avec le roi l'a
fait roi des 8
j'avais pas trop prévu ce coup alors
sans doute là effectivement on pouvait
défendre en lâchant un petit peu en
faisant touré suite d'abord ouais mais
là je vais prendre un set et puis après
il ya toujours j'ai ouï a souffert du
temps mais je sais si c'est déjà
difficile en fait pour le noir parce que
je pensais être beaucoup mieux
d'accord donc le fait roi des 8es long
rock et à la main c'est là le grand
roque ont envisagé tout à l'heure
finalement le final de fermer en trois
coups fait qu au lieu d'un seul je suis
pas sûr que j'aime de lumière rouge ffu
projet 6
oui alors c'est possible puisque la tour
ne peut pas faire toujours confiant on
ne peut pas prendre puisque la touriste
autorise ici moment d'apprendre pour ça
j'ai hésité pendant ces 5
et puis prendre d'abord assez sale
réfère aux h1 pour essayer de faire
qu'elle et 5 tout ça
c'est léger scène menace une fourchette
en retour et puis en plus ces attaques
là le pion si c'est ça dont on peut
prendre du cavalier ouais mais quand
même moi champ par exemple ici comme ça
comme ça et ici alléger sa perte quand
même trois cavaliers qui menace avec la
dame derrière qui faisait échec et mais
bon j'étais pas très sûr mais sous le
roi va vite revenir là là et les tours
sont liés je vais pas prendre des toits
le prendre en b2 mais bon je sais pas
peut-être pas j'ai voulu prendre le pion
mais d'accord ça qu'après c'est un petit
peu échappé quand même assez petit peu
le japon est donc un projet ici en
france et 6 finalement ouais il a fait
3,6 et c'est donc à elle ses chats tout
tranquille donc il semblerait que même
qu'elle ait perdu ses pions elle est un
peu calmé l'orage poids parce que là
parce qu'en fait il ya deux sortes chose
récupérer quand même b2o quelque chose
quoi est il bon c'est là en plus je dois
faire attention parce que par exemple si
je fais preuve cette piste est qu'il
peut y avoir des quatre des trucs comme
ça aide un coup à gauche s'en fout et
puis oui des cas plus quel est le fou 17
se réveille ça peut être assez assez
tendue qua non que je suis pas voulu
permettre des 4 enfin j'ai voulu garder
cavaliers ou quatre jours je suis venu
revenu en d3 avec le flou donc ça j'y
suis revenue en d3 sur des quêtes j'ai
cumulé au 4 comme ça rock ambiant ou
quatre ans
bloquent l'action du fond et on a une
case en décident en attaque le fossile à
l ac 3b vite il continue son petit
parcours d'arbre enfin tranquille vous
donc à la main voyez l'europe à la main
ça c'est quand même assez joli parce que
voilà et elle est à l'abri et les tours
sont liés voilà donc le gros problème
ira au centre est résolu en tout cas on
est bien sorti parce que c'était pas
évident je considère alors tu as un
problème c'est que le q5 est attaqué au
petit matin
ouais il a en fait j'ai toute façon je
me suis dit là je les perdrais plonge
j'ai essayé de transposer dont quelque
chose d'un peu essayé d'avoir un petit
avantage quand même positionne elle est
bloquée soulevé cet ange en quel lieu de
revenir avec mon camion des quatre
d'accord donc tu as fait que y aurait eu
des voix laquelle ya de l'idée est donc
effectivement tu protèges déjà des
quatre avec le fou allez on avait dit
d'ailleurs c'est le thème de la
française cette case et donc tu veux
sauter ici et sa boîte ce pion mais si
on boxe option boucle vous déjà et puis
je peux toujours forcé l'échangé fou et
b4 éventuels et les quatre force le fou
à s'échanger voici voilà de jouer
puisque fou 17 lalala pris en 5
alors du ce de celui là ouais ça va les
prendre 5
elle récupère le pion central pour
certains ça fait peur parce que j
suivante a pris soin purgé 6
oui mais elle prend à glace j'avais un
petit peu sous-estimé ça mais ce que
vont il ya quand même un clouage avec
des f4 ce que j'ai fait quelques
concessions qui les prend et 5
d'amérique être car les professeurs
d'aller prendre saine et juste à temps
dès lors si je vous lis parce que on se
dit qu'il ya que je me fous des six
puisque ça eh ben oui ça marche pas a
soutenu qu'il écrivait dans les sacs et
jolie c'est toujours des clous et et
commencèrent alors par exemple sur dame
c7 qui des clous aussi bien on vous
prend dans prend et après orange rouge
ou le câble est toujours en prison même
cavalier des quatre en fait il est en
fait là en fait un coin il fallait
absolument qu'elle fasse comprendre que
c'était c'était important s'était portée
ouais parce que sinon après l'es1
en fait elle a perdu en attendant faites
après oui fallait qu'elle fasse ou prend
un rêve de tout reprendre f2 et la dame
c'est cette somme c'est ça qui va s'en
sortait higway je pensais faire quelque
chose que vous travaillez d4 et prenez
en d3 d'échangés ans et 7 et puis on
prend des 3 mai le centre et un à ses
mobiles j'arrive pas à bloquer comme il
faut et du coup ça doit être égale à peu
près d'accord
mais oui de quoi le fait est là s'est
apprécié à la fedom des six qui est un
peu moins bon voilà et du coup là je
peux prendre ces cinq mois même prise et
elle fait pas d'homme prendre ce que tu
veux pas sur la trame français 5 toute
façon cavaliers des cas on regarde sur
dame prend calais des quatre lots cloud
étant prises et à paris la défense
elle doit faire des menées si soudaine
c7 et tourer et je vais je vais gagner
aussi voilà la localité attaquée lors le
seul coup c'est de l'avenir en c4
parlement ouais et maintenant simplement
de tout reprendre 6 par exemple août à
moins de changer voilà échanges et
indécise et on gagne le pion aussi ce
qui est très important là et enfouissent
voilà toujours se fout bessette et donc
ayant des 4 kilotonnes de la française
est donc ça montre bien l était pas fait
recette la casse des quatre lots fou de
cases blanches qui bouge pas qui est
derrière ces pions d'accord donc oui
c'est un peu précis se demander si
effectivement il aurait dû échanger tout
à fait donc sous prend elle le fait elle
lâché tour pro prend bien sûr voilà ce à
quoi l'agefi cap des 4 quand même menace
avec la même idée mais pour le faire en
fait très mal a fait autour des 8 pour
défendre sa dame défend la dame
il a j'ai fait tout re un tour en
t'aurais pu prendre aussi maintenant le
plus rage cette si elle touche autour
des 8 le pion h7 peut-être ouais c'est
vrai que c'est vrai que j'avais
l'impression que toi enfin j'entrais
dans un truc que j'avais un bond ou troy
avec +6 et je pense que c'est mieux un
peuple parce que en fait ce qui
t'intéresse ici surtout c'est qu'elle
arrive jamais à pousser les pions
c'est ça ou 5 pour pas se libérer et
donc ça c'est la cas de 5 étant glauque
et le pion 6 va tomber ou s'ils tombent
pas assez verrouillé quoi enfin voilà
d'accord j'ai préféré faire c'est cette
finale avec et prend des trois cavale et
prend là j'ai pris en d6
d'abord parce qu'il tenait à peu près
équivalente ou retomber si c'est une
première en d3 et la voilà on voit bien
c'est tour sont pas très bien placé
certains c5 et sur une colonne mais là
aucune case montrer nice alors ce café
est magnifique et ce pion d'être en
équipe type lions comme ça on se demande
ce qu'il fait d'armes le quart livre en
fait il est essentiel parce que on peut
pas venir taquiner le cavalier qui
contrôle t il un bon contrat les
contrôles double cette petite structure
pour les blancs l'air de rien la tour
empêche advitam eternam le 5 est donc en
fait l'événement ça a l'air de rien mais
ils sont en vie c'est en fait là c'est
oui j'ai un peu fait c'est quasiment
absolu non plus parce que les pièces ont
tout bloqué c'est difficile
la défendre rupture réussissent avec
tous ses 8,6 g mais solide voilà ouais
pas trop chaud a probablement et la
chair un trait avec le tour à tour f 800
il futur clou du coup le foot mouais je
venais de prendre six à la saucisse donc
ont cassé des clous et crabes et 7,3
bessette alors en baisse est sans doute
parce qu'en cas d'échec
elles veulent venir se servent des fins
de crise est si faible donc là j'ai fait
des tours aux 8 pour 8 et donc se fout
ce pion à un foutu c'est ça mais en fait
il faut que je fasse attention ne peut
pas le prendre n'importe quand pour
rentrer en finale deux tours et qu'elles
soient actives à une tour ces deux voies
la salle alors en chasse et de loin il
faut faire attention reste important par
exemple elle a fait tour c7 est donc
voilà si je le prends l affaire tour
c'est un échec on relève deux tours
c'est de récupérer b2
et monde c'est pas très clair du tout il
faut d'abord prendre de l'avant ensemble
du coup voilà c'est ce que j'ai fait
j'ai fait h 4 du coup puisque là elle a
pas trop de coups en fait h4 et page et
4 parce que j'ai 4 c'est peut-être un
peu imprécise sur kst mt 6 e 5 et jugé
que les transporteurs g7 le sec et le
fou attaque oui donc là je 4 est
peut-être plus plus précis way ou h3 pu
faire aussi peut-être pas je me suis dit
j'avance loin possible
ça peut être important à la fin oui
depuis il est avancé plus comme tu va
échanger tout sera proche de damas donc
la fée tour j'ai 16 c qui était le coup
que j'avais prévu voilà et maintenant
qu'elle est partie de la colonne elle
peut plus rentrer donc j'ai pris ma
manche j'ai transposé dans le film ah
oui parce qu'elle est sortie la colonne
ces voix là voilà c'est ça tu as attendu
que le sort de la colonne c est
maintenant tu dis bon maintenant je veux
maintenant j'ai pris donc comprendre
aussi souvent tout re prendre tour celle
là ouais ouais
et là je pensais que croise ici c'était
un peu mieux ces six ouais parce que mon
âge que je peux prendre est allé manger
le pion à mais peut-être qu'elle est
active avec le roi
oui on sait qu en d 4 il va prendre des
trois gars c'est pas ça donnait un peu
plus de contre chance elle a échangé
réussissent tout de suite tard il a fait
tout rejet 3 et c'est vrai que là les
coupés droit voilà
mais c'est vrai qu'elle doit essayer de
jouer actifs je pense donc qu'elle a
fait tout g3 mais c'est vrai qu'après je
me retrouve avec d'options passé lié
entre le pont des voilages est très
important puis on passe est lié c'est
vrai qu'en plus j'ai la tour qui est en
place et donc ils vont pouvoir avancer
assez vite
j'avais pensé que c'était gagnant de
recettes par touriste être p6t6 approche
comprend alors voilà d'autres pions
passé lié en finale deux tours
quand le roi elwes souvent gagnant parce
qu'on peut jamais arrêtés quand ils sont
ensemble avec eux soutenu avec une peau
en fait oui c'est là qu'en plus elle
elle ces primes dès qu'il sera passé mon
doigt et pas trop loin et du coup il lui
il veut arrêter le plus rentable que lui
pour les arrêter cela les autos auquel
prend même à la paperie en fait elle a
fait faire passer 5 allait le prendre à
être le voilà il m'empêchait d'avancer
fillon ah oui parce que tour bloque donc
du coup j'ai fait rouages de feu c'est
un peu compliqué j'étais pas sûr j'ai
hésité un peu agaçant et tout s'annonce
était il seul ce match mais bon je me
suis dit qu'elle avait lavé avoir du mal
à arrêter de changer quand même notion
f2 tout prend des 3es g4 pour prendre
d'être en attendant g4 et là je vous
parie que c'est vrai que même si elle va
piquer les pions vieille dame ça va être
ça va
très vite c'est bien plus gilroy qui
contrôle les cases derrière pour la tour
donc ça va être compliqué pour elle de
l'arrêter surtout à perdre beaucoup de
temps en fait ouais donc là à ses
blessures des quatre crois que c'est
comme ça c'était là on déclare très ou 4
à la whey la fer vale cash
ouais on est au 37e wales ne s'était
passé quelque chose comme ça voire des 4
et puis j'ai continué à avancer sur les
g5 rome 4-3 mien non à la faye cheikh la
la la fesci chèque et c'est vrai que
c'est ça l'état joue un rôle 3 ouais
voilà tu là c'est un peu bizarre fin à
mon avis quand même il aurait dû tenter
d'essayer d'aller prendre des pions wii
voir ce que ça donne parce que là
maintenant elle a fait autour des 1 pour
passer la tour derrière mais c'est vrai
que celles en quoi ouais c'est très long
et les pions sont déjà très avancés en
plus des que même si l'autre aussi des
labos en fait d'avancé donc on voit mal
comment les noirs peuvent arrêter ça je
pensais déjà archi régnant fait la leur
et même trois des cinq je peux faire j 6
à 5
et après on fait le rêve 6,6 à rien
parce que je fais toujours toif cet
échec en fait les deux pions comme ça
avec la tour devant c'est si narita
c'est bon j'ai pas besoin du roi en fait
pour promouvoir très très sport c'est
bien à savoir quand vous avez deux pions
passé lié en finale deux tours comme ça
quasiment les yeux fermés à quelques
détails près et s'il faut faire
attention comme mais en gros c'est
toujours beaucoup plus fort que même si
l'adversaire depuis ont éloignés par
exemple voilà depuis ont passé mais
éloigné parce que leur avez votre tour
vous arrivera à les bloquer alors que
lui il et puis on passe etc
j - après ça s'est fini tour d un pour
dire j'ai six g6 quand même voilà tanger
ans donc j'ai fait h5 commencé dans tous
les cas en fait je vais faire g7 est
suisse ayant rien à faire si ce protégé
c'est depuis tourache 8 et on peut pas
empêcher la dame après la tour contrôler
ce pion le tout faire madame c'est ce
qui s'est passé en fait une fois
laférois détroit g7 pour détroit g7 d466
où c'est très lent parce qu'on joue son
rôle et devant ça ne pas avancer ses
deux étoiles et l' abandon
on peut rejouer quelques coups imaginant
même comprend ce pioche pour un beau nom
pour celui entre us mais je vois la dame
on peut faire une dame et le truc c'est
qu'il ya une jeune dame qui arrive après
quoi moi ça va très vite
par exemple ici bas simplement on fait
le fait déjà c'est un échec là en fait
je viens rien du tout oui parce que le
surveille
si elle chrome os 6 - si elle prend le
roy vienne bloquer le pion à profit la
dame et si elle le jour dmb laurent
match et frime d'ailleurs encore à
detroit ben ça sert à rien puisqu'on
fait cher pour voir revient à 3-2 et je
finis puis si elle abandonne avec 13 ont
donc belle partie belle transformation
technique à la fin ouais c'est vrai que
bon j'essaie lavera 3 2 échecs
intermédiaires qui a été important et
c'est vrai qu'à partir de là alors on
s'attendait à ce que tu gagnes cette
partie en tout cas on s'était dit ciel
gagne pas celle là on peut dire adieu
elle peut dire adieu au titre
parce qu'elle a les blancs elle joue
quand même une joueuse qui est en
difficulté dans le tournoi et si elle
veut recoller au peloton c'est le moment
ou jamais de quoi ouais
mais on sait jamais je veux dire ici
fille voilà un mauvais choix dans le
vertueux comme ça m'est arrivé je
l'entends noah et il voit là en tout
peut arriver sur une partie mais en
l'occurrence tard en python 3 pour
l'instant joueurs moi je regarde pas
trop ce qui se passe j'essaye de bien
jouer façon voilà quand quand je suis
arrivé ici j'avais pas spécialement
voilà deux objectifs même si on peut se
dire ou numéro de tenues décontractées
ouais ouais parce que parce que c'est
vrai qu'en fait ce qui s'est passé c'est
que les deux dernières années je suis
arrivé ici en tant que favorite
quasiment en tout cas je vous la
remettez pas correct on voit là je
voulais gagner et j'arrive et je voulais
gagner c'était clair et en fait je
j'étais très stressée que tenir autour
de toi même en fait et j'ai pas réussi à
contrôler ce stress je prenais pas de
plaisir quand jouer ce qui fait que
voilà je vous ai mal et en plus c'était
voilà c'est un plaisir aucun donc
l'élasthanne et et contempler là je suis
contente je joue détendu j'ai fait des
bonnes parties je pense pas tout à fait
la tête quand tu as perdu face à ambri
ben quand on perd son goût et c'est
toujours un petit peu bon c'est un peu
ouais c'est un peu frustrant quoi donc
bon bah oui évidemment moi c'est jamais
s'est jamais marrant perdre mais bon ça
va j'ai pas j'ai pas été complètement
démoralisé j'ai réussi et que même après
jouer correctement donc
donc voilà où paris rempli il remplace
trois parties j'espère continuer à bien
jouer
et puis voilà on est passé en mer cette
phase est âpre en conclure pour la suite
des événements c'est d'être dans la
saison c'est quoi tes objectifs
ensuite après ce championnat est alors
mal en fait j'ai décidé
de jouer un peu moins partir de l'année
prochaine c'est à dire là jusque là ça
fait plusieurs années je jouais
énormément je joue trop je pense j'ai du
coup j'ai pas beaucoup de temps morts
entre les tournois
tu veux me préparer ton calme du coup vu
que j'ai pas de trop de temps mort
maximum deux semaines je rentre chez moi
et je me repose que j'ai pas le temps de
m'entraîner tout ça donc
donc du coup je vais essayer de moins
jouer et m'entraîner beaucoup plus tous
les jours séguin
voilà un peu plus d'énergie après caen
joue et voilà ivoire voir ce que ça
donne voilà enfin comme ça donc du coup
la prochainement
j'ai pas grand chose de prévu la
prochaine grosse échéance sûr ça va être
les championnats d'europe par équipes
avec l'équipe de france mais qui sont à
reykjavik
donc là on a une belle équipe tout qui
joue cette année baril sebag et là tu es
là quatre titres au compteur mariana
grenat je sais pas combien
mais elle joue pas beaucoup nationale
bon bon mari bon allez y est très fort
tourné la scène il ya aussi un miracle
vous êtes toutes les
il ya via poli mais aussi des cercles
jacky qui jouent pas qui joue pas une
nationale sommet donc il ya quand même
au niveau de 1350 motion voilà et puis
et puis sylvia colosse qui est voilà je
sais très solide qui en équipe qui a
absolument rien à lui reprocher elles
vont très bien
voilà donc qui sait l'être vous visez le
nombre d'heures minimum quoi ce qu'on
peut viser le podium avec cet équipement
est très bon c'est toujours pareil il
faut être en forme et je plaide europe
c'est dur c'est avec mathieu cornette
qui vous accompagnent ouais c'est ça la
chose avec mathieu c'est vrai que
parfois il est un peu critique et je
trouve ça dommage parce que c'est vrai
que c'est quand même un homme c'est dans
votre tour les sélectionnables tous les
sports wii seront sous le feu de la
critique de la bd pourquoi il a
sélectionné palu bon on va pas parler de
ça c'est la question
enfin pas tout le monde qui a la chance
d'être entraînée par un des meilleurs
grands maîtres français ça fait plus
j'veux dire il travaille avec des tops
grand maître donc voilà
au niveau des préparations ça ça aide
beaucoup
il est là une belle saison ils passent
ils passent beaucoup de temps pour vous
avez hélas il sera physiquement avec
vous
par contre il n'était pas au championnat
du monde féminin compagnie aussi en fait
c'est le championnat du monde féminin je
ne sais pas une compétition par équipes
la fédération ne s'implique pas là
dedans
d'accord donc tout ça passe ton chemin
personnel quoi c'est ça après nous on
fait comme on veut moi j'avais beaucoup
préparé avant et voilà sur place de la
personne n'acceptait pas forcément
nécessaire j'étais en contact parce
qu'elle est d'accord on peut se faire
espionner par sky propension avec les
américains qui contrôlent les
communications par et il faut faire
attention quand même à sa sage et page
encore là c'est parra nouvelle saison
qui s'annonce alors mais on va voir moi
je fais là un peu différente approche
que je vais tenter parce que c'est vrai
que ça fait mal d'années que chez eux
mêmes lots ça c'est clair que ya pas
vraiment progression est donc là voilà
je vais essayer de m'entraîner à la fois
avoir à la fois voilà surprend échiquéen
fois sur le plan physique aussi oui
parce qu'il faut tenir la distance dans
les grands tournois
sur le coup je fais beaucoup de sport
donc oui
et voilà comment une bonne condition et
voilà et aussi essayer de genre un peu
mieux l'aspect l'aspect mental qui fait
un peu défaut et je pense c'est pour ça
que que je stagne depuis plusieurs
années donc je vais essayer de
travailler ça et voir ainsi à passer un
nouveau cap ou pas dernier point
vraiment dernière question pour aller
aux championnats du monde donc tu étais
qualifié cette année dont c'était le
premier
voilà et mais je suppose que tu as
l'ambition d'y retourner et il faut
faire quoi pour se qualifier enfin celui
des qualifications se passe par le
championnat d'europe dacquois donc
individuel individuel donc en général
c'est à peu près les 15 premières faut
finir dans les 15 premières du
championnat d'europe individuel tu as le
temps avant que malheureusement cette
année c'était pendant le top 12
répondent donc aucune française n'a
participé personne à personne n'a pu y
aller mais c'est vrai que en fait les
dates du championnat d'europe on est
annoncée très tard le top 10 était déjà
planifiée pour ces dates là donc
malheureusement en surface et à côté
d'une chance est qualifié et voilà
l'année prochaine on sait pas où ce sera
encore voilà j'espère que cette fois ce
sera pas en même temps que culte aux
blues ou quelque chose comme ça parce
que c'est vrai que c'est dommage
toujours de prendre le père noël comme
un vrai jeu n'est pas très sûr il ya
énormément ainsi de compétition mais bon
voilà un championnat d'europe
bon c'est vrai que c'est dommage qu'ils
soient pas avance annoncé un peu un peu
plus à l'avant ce qu'on puisse
s'organiser parce que on peut rien faire
quoi donc voilà
j'espère pouvoir le jouer et bien merci
vous pousse aussi merci à toi d'en
devenir dans le studio à monatélé pour
ce championnat de france donc et puis
que vous avez des indications sur ta
carrière aussi merci de nous avoir
suivis ils m'ont je donne rendez-vous
pour une prochaine émission de télé avec
d'autres joueurs de ce national 2015
cinquantaine 2015 merci à tous au revoir